I love Detroit man it was very chill I
liked it it was [ __ ] and that'd be it
ain't like everybody make it seem like
it's really fun I [ __ ] loved it I was
like I tell everybody I'm like yo
Detroit's fire everybody was super nice
I also had zero clue that you guys are
like you could throw a rock and hit
Canada
do you go to Canada sometimes no
just why not it's like you could just
drive over there I'm back I just got my
passport and I just stopped being a
felon but I ain't stopped being a felon
I just got off felony probation so I
like how you said that I just stopped
being a felon by the way congratulations
I'm glad you made that life choice but
uh do you have because it's hard to get
into Canada if you have a felony right
yeah but could you get are you fine
though I'm trying to get cool with Drake
I mean I'm sure that'll happen right he
hasn't latched on to a Detroit artist
yet for sure he'll latch on to somebody
my cousin here Detroit artist he just
took a picture with Drake
um [ __ ] that's and little baby took the
picture I'm like that's fire I am
surprised that Drake hasn't um
really dug in with like a Detroit artist
yet it feels like the type of thing he
would do you know he brought um cash all
out one time
I mean
how long ago was that like 2017 or 18 19
maybe probably something like that you
probably remember it yeah he for sure
Castro's a legend Dej loves a legend
shout out to Dave